imagine you've got the skill set to be a
top surgeon but you lack the ability to
emotionally disengage from the people
that you're operating on you're not
going to cut it all right ruthlessness
fearlessness mental toughness
self-confidence coolness Under Pressure
emotional Detachment Focus charm none of
those traits is necessarily a problem in
itself in fact all of them dialed up at
the right levels can actually prove
rather useful
Kevin Dunn welcome to the show Cheers
Chris thanks for having me mate how are
you I'm well thank you how do you
describe what you do for work what is
your area of expertise if there is one
well I'm a psychologist that's number
one
um I'm talking to you uh from Down Under
mate in uh in Adelaide
uh where it's 8 30 in the morning at the
moment
um so bright and early
uh and I'm professor of the public
understanding of psychology at the
University of Adelaide so that is
Australia's first professor of such a
thing so I'm Australia's first professor
of the public understanding of
psychology which basically means that I
uh bring psychology to the general
public uh so psychology is a very broad
church it's got loads of sub-disciplines
and and different areas of study
everything from forensic to social to
developmental to educational to sport
all those kinds of things
and so what my job is uh down here is to
collate the best of that kind of uh
information and
um make it accessible to the general
public so that's what I do for a living
that's my day job uh my area of
expertise
um as most people will probably
recognize me for is Psychopaths uh so
um many years ago about 10 years ago now
I wrote a book called The Wisdom of
psychopaths which became very
controversial
um and it's still I think the only book
that
um suggests that Psychopaths aren't all
bad that
um actually you know we have this
stereotype of psychopaths being rapist
and serial killers and what have you but
actually if you were to look inside the
Realms of special 40s for example you'd
also find people who are high on what I
call the psychopathic Spectrum
um so when I wrote wisdom of psychopaths
as I say became a controversial book
um I became quite well known and it was
on the basis of that really that I
suppose you know if you can say this
kind of thing I kind of made my name in
Psychology so you would be the current
Australian equivalent in psychology of
Brian Cox for physics in the Years
listen don't put me down like that man
don't you dare don't you dare put me
down like that what did it know actually
Brian's over here doing a big tour at
the moment yeah um he's uh he's doing a
great big tour
um yeah I mean I've got a listen I'd I'd
uh I'd go I'd go with that um yeah at
the moment uh obviously not doing the
big stadium shows uh like Brian but uh
one can only hope okay but uh yeah no
ABS absolutely mate
talk to me about
the Adaptive explanation for how
psychopathy exists why would it be that
Evolution creates humans that have that
particular mix of traits
well it's true and I think first of all
it's probably a good idea to Define what
a what a psychopath actually is uh Chris
because there's a lot of misnomers about
Psychopaths mate um so might help you
listeners to just get a kind of a brief
description what they are I mean it's
true isn't it when most people
hear the word psychopath I instantly
think of
um you know on the Silver Screen serial
killers like Hannibal Lecter
um and in real life
um serial killers like Ted Bundy but
actually when psychologists like myself
talk about Psychopaths mate we're
actually referring to a distinct subset
of individuals with a specific
constellation of personality traits uh
such as uh ruthlessness fearlessness
mental toughness
self-confidence coolness Under Pressure
uh emotional Detachment uh Focus charm
Charisma and of course those those
trademark deficits in in conscience and
empathy that you hear so much about now
none of those traits is necessarily a
problem in itself Chris in fact all of
them dialed up at the right levels and
deployed within the right context can
actually prove rather useful okay the
key here as I've always said lies in
context and level so imagine for
instance a personality mixing desk
probably the best way of thinking about
it on which those traits I've just
outlined comprise the um the the kind of
hodgepodge of knobs and Sliders okay
twiddle them up and down in various
combinations
and you arrive at two conclusions all
right the first one is that there is no
objectively correct setting at which
those dials might be positioned but
rather it will invariably depend on uh
cotton context on the particular set of
circumstances you might happen to find
yourself in
the second and this comes back to
answering your question the second is
there exists certain jobs or professions
for example that by their very
definition
um might demonstrate what we might call
Precision engineered psychopathy that
might by their very nature have those
dials turned up a little bit higher than
you might find in everyday life so give
you a couple of examples imagine you've
got
um the skill set to be a top surgeon all
right but that you lack the ability to
emotionally disengage from the people
that you're operating on we're not going
to cut it all right well quite literally
in fact you're not going to cut it sorry
mate I didn't mean that on purpose
um imagine you've got the um financial
and
um strategic smarts uh to be a top
business person but you lack the ability
to fire someone if they're
underperforming that ruthlessness to let
someone go or the coolness Under
Pressure to ride out a storm or the
sheer
uh balls necessary to take a calculated
risk when appropriate okay again you're
not going to make it I imagine you've
got the
um ability to be a top lawyer but do you
like the almost pathological
self-confidence that almost narcissism
to be the center of attention in the
middle of a pack courtroom now those uh
characteristics those traits I've just
outlined for you there ruthlessness
fearlessness self-confidence emotional
Detachment and coolness under pressure
comprise five core characteristics of
the psychopathic personality now would
you say they were dysfunctional in those
contexts I certainly wouldn't and I've
written books on that and papers on that
so to answer your question now we've
defined psychopathy and given you
examples in everyday life if we go back
to say the days of our ancient
evolutionary forefathers you know a
couple of million years ago when we were
living in small groups on the east
African savannas
you could imagine that there were
certain characteristics such as the
aggression uh the ability to take risks
the ability to be predatorial in terms
of hunting you can see how and also the
ability to tell lies actually to
infiltrate other groups maybe to get
information out of them you can see how
these kinds of characteristics which are
beneficial in the modern era actually
might have evolved in eras
um long gone
um so the the kind of as I say the James
Bond profile the ruthless Fearless
remorseless character actually that we
see today does have its uses not just in
Special Forces and and um and the agency
there my five or six those kinds of
things but in in everyday jobs like
surgery in business for example
uh but also they would have been
selected for many years ago for the
reasons
um that that I just outlined so even
though uh uh Raider or infiltrator of
other tribe wasn't an occupation it was
a role it was a role that needed filling
and because that needed filling it was
adaptive across an entire group for
certain members of that group probably
not too many because if you had 150
person tribe and all of them there would
be way too much chaos but I'm gonna
guess that the amount of psychopaths
that we have proportionally at the
moment would be the amount on average
that was effective to keep a group
moving forward
you've absolutely nailed it there Chris
in fact there's a branch of psychology
um and information science if you were
to draw the Venn diagrams between
psychology and information science and
decision making uh you've got
um an area that we call Game Theory you
might have heard of it
um and when game theorists model the
incidents uh the prevalence of
psychopathy Psychopathic personalities
um within the general public which is
roughly about one percent of people are
psychopaths what we would regard as
diagnosed Psychopaths
um then Game Theory when you look at the
game theory models they actually bear
that out in the computer algorithms as
well uh so you're absolutely right you
can't have it well you can't have a
society which is all psychopath because
it wouldn't be a society that's the
first thing
um it's interesting an interesting
parallel is with the uh with the Vikings
many years ago they had
um a group of
um well I suppose you could call them
very early Special Forces uh soldiers
called the Berserkers and it's where we
get the word Berserk from and the I mean
the Vikings were pretty Fierce enough
but the Berserkers took it to an
absolute extreme so they kind of were
they were almost like the Special Forces
win the Vikings and they fought with uh
an absolute trance-like frenzy uh and
obviously contributed to the Vikings
fearsome reputation down the years the
problem with the Berserkers was they
were fantastic in Wartime but they were
absolutely terrible in peacetime because
they were constantly looking for fights
um probably a bit like your days in the
Newcastle nightclubs mate actually I
think there was some Berserkers today
definitely some Viking DNA floating
around well talk to me when it comes to
Psychopaths one of the interesting
things there confidence Under Pressure
the ability to deal with that stuff what
was that study that looked at penalty
takers trying to win versus penalty
takers trying not to lose or trying to
catch up on the score sheet yeah it's
very interesting that so uh there was a
study which looked at
um what people and obviously England
we've got a World Cup coming up
um uh next month and don't God's sake
don't ask me about that mate
um but um yeah there was a study done
which looked at who was most likely to
uh score penalties in a penalty shootout
and you know most people watching a
penalty shootout would think that the
pressure is equally high on everybody
uh but actually when you look and you
you kind of analyze it there's different
pressures depending on whether you are
taking a penalty to keep your team in
the competition
or whether you are taking a penalty to
put your team through uh so if you're
taking a penalty to put your team
through uh the pressure is actually less
than uh the pressure on you if you're
taking a penalty to keep your team in
because our brains have evolved a bias
towards loss rather than reward
um if you think back to our evolutionary
history if you face with a rustle in the
bushes and you make a wrong decision and
you think oh well that's nothing
um then it can come out of the Bush and
eat you pretty quickly it might not be
the brief it might be a saber-toothed
tiger
um so actually our brains have evolved a
bias towards loss aversion we don't want
to make a mistake we don't want to have
a a situation where we are complacent
and where we mistake something uh which
is eventually going to eat us so which
is going to lose us our lives so those
kinds of evolutionary buyers biases that
evolved many years ago are still with us
today in in football stadiums when it
comes to penalty shootout so if you're
taking a penalty which if you miss is
going to put your team out that loss is
really Weighing on your mind way more
than if you know you're going to score
and you're going to put your team
through the stakes at least the way the
brain computes it Chris are much higher
if you're taking a penalty to stay in do
you know what the relative percentages
are I think it's something like off the
top of my head mate I think it's
something like 62 of people
score
uh when it's putting when you're taking
a penalty to uh keep your team in and I
think it's roughly about 90 score when
it's uh taken penalty to put your team
through uh so it's something like that
it's something like 60 90. so it's still
the majority of people score but when
you're putting it when you're taking a
pillow to put your team through
way more people score I suppose although
if you're talking about England mate I'm
not sure maybe that starting maybe that
study doesn't want wasn't done in
England yeah this was never
um yeah what that means is
when you're doing a normal penalty
shootout let's say that you're into the
um knockout stages of a competition and
you get to the end there is a huge
Advantage there is a 30 advantage to the
team that gets to take the penalties
first let's say that each team continues
to score
that's right it's 4-4 with the final two
penalties to go you've got it team one
misses and team two scores yeah team one
is out but Team One never faces the
situation game theoretically of that 30
disparity between the success or failure
uh concern so there is a huge I mean
that's the most important way more
important than who which end do you get
who gets to kick off first the most
important thing perhaps in an entire
competition is who gets to take the
penalties first it's it's a literally is
who wins the toss you're absolutely
right that that um that a what we call
in Psychology interact uh you know that
who wins that chart interacts with you
know your ability uh to actually score
penalty shootouts are very interesting
there's a lot of you a lot of how you
can almost have a degree in penalty
shootouts you know you could almost like
set up an entire degree course in it
um there's loads and loads of different
ways the penalty shootout can go wrong
how things pray on the mind
um the best thing to do in a penalty
shootout
is well first of all to practice them
which England are now doing that's the
first thing Chris uh the second thing is
to make your mind up and just go for it
so literally
um a lot of penalties are missed not in
the run-up which uh people think is is
often the case but actually the penalty
is often missed when you put the ball
down if you imagine a player if you put
the ball down and then you turn around
and you walk away from the ball to a
point where you're going to begin your
run-up
and that point in that when you put the
ball down and you turn away and You
Begin the walk to your run-up that is
when it goes wrong most of the time
because that's all of a sudden when last
minute doubts or changes of mind can
creep in
um all that kind of noise uh that that
usually disrupts the clarity of thought
uh that can creep in and you can change
your mind at the last minute without you
even knowing you're gonna do it so the
way around that is to absolutely decide
from the word go no matter what happens
it's top left bottom right or what have
you
um from a psychological point of view
that's the best way of winning a penalty
shootout to be absolutely confident to
be absolutely certain
I also heard that 9 out of 10 deaths on
Everest happen on the way down and you
had some similar story about fighter
pilots in World War II maybe that was
super successful in the dogfight but
then not so good afterward
s absolutely right well
um yes that's true summer in World War
II
um some of the uh greatest fighter
pilots
um who were absolutely brilliant
in aerial combat uh ruthless and and
fearless
um lost their lives on the journey home
because such was their laser-like focus
to winning the dogfights at all costs
um that they took their minds off the
fuel gauges
um and that's a typical Psychopathic
characteristic might I say so
um you know if you it's really
interesting actually I've I know quite a
few fighter pilots uh through various
contracts I'll have in the military and
there's uh there's a kind of an old joke
that you can tell a fire pilot within
about a minute of talking to them
because they'll tell you they are
um and it's uh it's actually very true
and they've got a license to do that
because just as James Bond has a license
to Kill I think we all have various
licenses to do something you don't get a
fighter pilot without an ego okay in
order to be Top Gun you've got to have a
bit of an ego Chris and I think people
who do that kind of job are licensed to
have that that kind of ego and they're
also pre they might be very nice men but
they're also pretty ruthless uh pretty
fearless and very cool Under Pressure
um now what you find as I was saying
going back to what you're saying in the
olden days during during the second
World War that ruthlessness and
fearlessness sometimes uh would would
result in tunnel vision where the pilots
were so intent on winning dog fights at
all costs that actually they took their
minds off the fuel gauges and of course
ran out of fuel on the way home
um and um and paid the penalty obviously
so um yeah absolutely right it's all
there's a balance to be struck mate
there's a balance to be struck between
you know getting the job done and I'm
playing a percentage game you've got
this quote from your new book which says
what makes the number the optimal number
of categories for anything is usually a
trade-off between practicality and
precision
yeah what do you mean by that why did
Evolution give creatures the ability to
categorize at all
well if you think about it Chris
um everything out there is on a
Continuum okay so you could have
um gender sexual orientation race skin
color uh colors of the electromatic
spectrum everything out there is gray
and in order to make sense of reality in
order to work out how it's multitude of
different elements relate to and
interact with each other
we need to dissect its
um amorphous unstructured content into
smaller sharper
self-contained bite-sized units okay we
in order to to make sense of reality
this Continuum
um we need to construct for ourselves
the illusion of a checkerboard surface
okay along which we can move sense and
and reason like rational thinking chess
pieces in an orderly predictable and
rule-based fashion otherwise everything
and anything would mean anything and
everything we've got to have categories
in the world it was really funny
actually only yesterday I was sitting in
the Adelaide over having a having a bit
of lunch and there was a
um not far from where I live and a
groundsman without cutting the grass and
he was mowing it you know like you know
ground from a couple of grass they cut
patterns and he was going up and down up
and down up and down and then he was
going across on the cross and across and
it struck me to rule metaphor for Life
mate because actually you know reality
out there is just one Big C agree big
one big fear green grass but our brains
kind of think the way lawnmowers cut
they think in Far straight lines
um and as a result of the grass cutting
here it kind of it basically turned the
the sea of green grass into a latch of
lime and emerald as you know and that's
very much the way our brains dissect and
cut up uh reality we must have
categories in the world in order to make
sense of it in order to survive I mean
give an example if you didn't have pass
and failing exams what would be the
point of having exams okay now I know
this is an unfair one but what's the
point of having speed limits well
otherwise everyone's going to be driving
as fast or as slow as they want
now if you're done doing 34 in a I think
it's 10 isn't it so rule so if you're
done doing 34 in a in a 30 mile an hour
zone right technically you can get away
with 33.
um if you're done doing 34 it might seem
really unfair
one mile an hour over the limit but okay
so what are you going to do about that
well okay what about make it 37 well
okay what what if you what if you're
doing 36 well he makes him 36 and you're
done 37. again you're going to think it
is unfair so we have to be able to draw
lines
in this multitude of continua that are
out there Chris in order to make sense
of reality and in order to to make sense
of the relationships between different
parts of it now
to go back to your question our brains
evolve what I call a categorization
instinct
for that reason in order to make sense
of reality in order to make it more
predictable in order to enable us to
behave rationally and in order to
simplify things okay
um great quote one of my favorite quotes
of all time by Noel Gallagher and his
brother Liam sums it all up and he said
that Liam is a man with a thought in a
world of soup and I think I think we're
all men with and women we're born with
forks in a world of soup mate we we we
have we live in this kind of liquid
amorphous structure and our brains have
kind of got this kind of black and white
way of trying to capture it and it
doesn't work and that's where a lot of
the problems arise in in everyday life
because we we we're born with these
binary black and white brains that we
evolved many years ago and yet
technological advancement has produced
the world Which is far more complex than
the world in which our ancestors grew up
in
um so um where it gets interesting I
think is when
other needs apart from uh Simplicity and
functionality start taking over from the
original needs for categorization now I
think a great example of this now I'm
not digging anyone out here by the way I
think a great example of this occurred a
few years ago on a on a budget Airline
um where you know when you're on a on an
any Airline you get the duty-free
trolley coming down selling perfumes and
what have you uh what a duty uh trolley
kind of start coming down the aisle
um and one of the passengers on the
plane took exception to the fact that
the perfumes were divided up into male
and female and they thought that was
very last century
um and they wrote a letter of complying
to the airline saying look this is yeah
sure you can do better than that you
know this is
um Jen this is you know pandering to the
binary gender kind of stuff
um you know actually these should all be
put in the same draw and they shouldn't
be differentials made between male and
female and actually the airline I
believe acquiesced to that
um now that's very interesting so you're
objecting to male female categories on
the basis of identity
and yeah if you think about what that
means it absolutely
um decreases the functionality of
selling perfumes on a plane because if
you're not a perfume Aficionado I don't
know whether Givenchy whatever is you
know a male or a female perfume somebody
after they could be buying a present for
their wife or their or their husband or
whatever so if you've got them all in
the same draw you're kind of doubling
your search time in a sense because
you're raveling around trying to find
wherever it is Imagine you've got one or
another yeah it's easy to find it
imagine if we had all of our clothing
stores where instead of there being a
men's flora and a woman's floor they
were all just mixed together and you
couldn't work out actually is this my is
this a guy's pair of jeans or is this a
girl's pair of jeans you'd have to swipe
through twice as much
in order to get through that yeah right
why are putting it so what you're
talking about is that we have a
environment now with far more complexity
than we were used to when we try and
apply our pattern identification
thinking and to try to categorize things
that sometimes gets hijacked absolutely
right that that's exactly that's you've
nailed it with the uh with the clothing
analogy an even better one than well you
know actually the perfume analogy I'm
sure there would be people that would be
uh would be pushing for something like
that but that is where you get we we
evolve to categorize and the
categorization instinct to simplify the
world
and we've got to be careful that in the
current day and age
um that original categorization Instinct
for those original reasons isn't
hijacked by other needs that may well be
important but actually
don't simplify the world at all and make
it much more complex and then make it
far more difficult to make decisions for
the benefit of most people so that's
that's exact a great example of this is
um is the color spectrum that's what
most people understand so when you look
at a rainbow Chris and you stand away
from it you see seven primary colors you
see red orange yellow green blue indigo
and violet however the closer you get to
a spectrum the less clear and apparent
those seven primary colors become and
actually when you get right up close to
say red and orange it's very very
difficult in fact impossible
to tell the colors apart when you look
on the border when does red fade into
orange when does orange Fade Into yellow
it's actually impossible because there's
infinite gradations so why do we
perceive seven colors well we perceive
seven colors at a distance because our
brains have made a decision for us over
millions of years of evolutionary
history that actually sevens about the
optimal number of colors that we need to
see in order to get by all right we
don't need to see four million shades of
red it's a waste of time mate so we can
get by with seven colors our brains are
kind of thought okay that's about right
so there you go now incidentally of
course that's just Western cultures
there are some cultures such as the
barimo in Papua New Guinea that don't
see a difference between blue and green
actually it's called Knoll blue and
green are the same color
yeah oh yeah mate yeah so I mean so that
we're talking here from a from a western
you know you're in America I'm in
Australia we're both from the UK
um we're talking about our own
perspective but actually they're you
know seven primary colors there are some
um cultures in a Royal in around the
world geniusly four or five
um so for example I mean a very uh good
friend of mine a colleague um two
colleagues Jules Davidoff and Debbie
Roberson give them a bit of a plug
um have done lots of studies with um
tribes in Papua New Guinea and also the
himba tribe
um down in um in Namibia Northern
Namibia and Africa
um and they've looked at you know if you
present various color swatches you know
like the old Dulux color swatches if you
present 20 shades of green decide berin
mode I think it's a brewing mode drives
personally Pappy New Guinea they will
and they're also very very slightly
different they will be able to pinpoint
those minute differences between those
20 shades of green if you were to show
us me and you those 20 shades of green
we're probably looking to go can't tell
the difference at all however if you
were to then put a green Swatch next to
a blue swatch
me and you could tell the difference
very easily but the berimo probably
wouldn't be able to do it very
interesting that's how the brain works
mate okay so what happens if people
categorize too narrowly
if people get into this categorization
across their entire life this has
something to do with hoarders I think
that's right yeah so Studies have been
done uh looking at hoarders and if you
categorize too narrowly
so if you think so most of us would you
know if you think of say like um a
washing up liquid bottle
um we would be able to say okay uh one
washing up liquid bottle who cares you
know there's other washing up Liquid
bottles which
um you know they're all the same pretty
much
um you know we can do with one uh
they're all in the same category pretty
much we can you know do without them you
know one one will do us
hoarders look at it the other way
hoarders are unable to see the
commonalities between say a particular
object or entity like a washing up
bottle every single one is different and
has its own unique kind of features and
so if you start thinking like that
it's very difficult to throw one away or
throw a knife you've got to any of them
it's difficult to throw 19 of them away
and just keep the one because actually
they're not the same thing as you and I
might see it they're all got their own
individual idiosyncratic features about
them and so when we think about hoarders
there's a lot of other things going on
as well but if you think about hoarders
as being uh oh you know they're just mad
or crazy or filthy or whatever
actually as usual uh when you look at
the psychology behind it uh the brain
works in very mysterious ways and I call
uh in my book I call uh hoarding a
categorization disorder uh because it's
we're just seeing category they're
seeing categories of objects in a
different way to us whereas we look at
say I don't know
um a newspaper as being okay you know
there's loads of newspapers loads of
different editions
um you know we don't need 5 000 you know
newspaper or whatever all tied up in
bundles they see it very differently
each one has got its own individual
properties and though and so each one
must therefore be preserved and that's
why it's very very difficult
um for
um a hoarders to throw stuff away
incidentally
the reverse of that is um you might know
this that there are some world leaders
um who simplify their wardrobes
um because they realize that every
decision that we make even a very simple
one like when we get up in the morning
what am I going to wear this morning
um is uh a drain on the brain's battery
and sometimes those decisions can
especially in terms of what you wear I
mean I know people that actually you
know
um and I'm speaking on behalf of a
friend here by the way because
um who actually really you know
sometimes take a very long time to
decide what they're going to wear in the
morning
um so Barack Obama for instance
um that's why he pretty much always wore
a dark blue or navy suit and a white or
a blue shirt and a very plain tie
because he didn't have to decide what he
was going to wear in the morning it was
pretty much a uniform
um and that's actually the psychology of
uniforms as well you don't have to waste
time deciding on abstract energies like
what am I going to wear what how am I
going to appear it's done for you uh and
so that ability to make decisions
automatically rather than you know well
who am I trying to appeal to what image
or Vibe am I trying to give off all
these kind of category selections we're
making our brains is taken away from us
because making decisions based on
categories can often be a real drain as
I say on on our cognitive batteries talk
to me about the relationship between
cognitive complexity and cognitive
closure because there's this Frankel
Brunswick study thing that I thought was
absolutely fascinating what's up yeah
well cognitive closure uh we all differ
we're all on a spectrum
and we all differ on the amount of
information that we need to make
decisions now that's not linked to
intelligence Chris okay
um so I know very intelligent people
that just differ in their ability in in
the amount of information they need to
feel comfortable to make a decision
so sometimes
we get people that we all know them we
need to chew over every single aspect of
a problem they can never get enough
information in order to make a decision
and they go on and on and on trying to
work out what the various aspects are
and how they relate to each other
sometimes on even very very simple
decisions those people have what we call
a very high need
for cognitive complexity
and let me get people who have a low
need for cognitive complexity who are
able to just see a couple of bits of
information say Okay more of a gut
instinct that's all I need
um and to add a little bit of complexity
to that situation uh we differ in terms
of our need for cognitive complexity in
various aspects of our life so for
example I kind of tend to need quite a
bit of information to make decisions I'm
allowed I'm licensed to do that I'm a
buffing I'm an academic mate however
when I go into a restaurant I'm like a
new restaurant I don't know I'm
lightning fast at looking at a menu
making up my mind what I want to eat now
don't ask me how that works mate I have
no idea but I'm very very good at going
to a restaurant saying okay that'll do
So within a restaurant situation a new
restaurant situation ordering the dinner
I have a low need for cognitive
complexity but there are other aspects
where I need a high need for cognitive
complexity
and that's linked to what we call
cognitive closure in other words our
ability to bring the shutters down on a
decision okay look that's it I've made
the decision on this
um I'm happy with that so a high need
for cognitive closure is is is is
related to cognitive complexity but not
the same thing I need the cognitive
closure is how comfortable we are at
keeping something going
um rather than you know just wanting a
need to get it over with and that
decision's done now of course won't go
into too much of all this but you've got
a two by two grid here haven't you got
people that have a high need and a low
need for cognitive complexity
and then you've got people with a high
and a load need for cognitive closure
and when you start going nuts is when
you've got a really high need for
cognitive complexity in other words you
need lots of information to make a
decision but you've also got a high need
for cognitive closure in other words you
might want all the information but
blimey you really want to shut something
down quickly the two kind of relate so a
high need for cognitive complexity High
need to get it over with
um actually that's when you start going
nuts now interestingly there have been
studies done uh looking at high needs
for uh cognitive complexity and actually
um again not to go into too much detail
about it but extremists and
fundamentalists of most Persuasions
have a low need for cognitive complexity
and a high need for cognitive closure in
other words they don't really need too
much information to make their minds up
and they're very happy making their
minds up sharpish so when you get and of
course it's not quite as simple as that
there's other
socio-cultural factors going on with
fundamentalism and extremism but
generally speaking if you look at a
cognitive profile if you've got a low
need for cognitive complexity in other
words you don't really need too much
information to make your mind up and a
high need for cognitive closure you like
to get things over with
you're kind of veering into extremism
category there uh territory there rather
well it makes a lot of sense that that
person will be very easily hijacked
right you know they want an answer to
why this particular incident occurred
somebody meets their threshold which
happens to be incredibly low they attack
their sense of self-worth to it and then
you're off to the races with ideology
and all of the protectionist strategies
that we create around ourselves we
attach ourselves to groups and so on and
so forth so I have to presume that the
inbuilt desire for categorization
has some relationship with tribalism
oh for sure absolutely right
um and there's these days it's very
interesting Chris when we look at what's
happening on the webmate social media
and the internet
um there's actually a phrase uh which is
which is uh done the during the rounds
started a couple of years ago
um almost in like the uh the post-truth
kind of stuff uh which which uh you know
reached his Peak with Trump
um called tribal epistemology
uh it's a long old word uh tribal
epistemology is basically well
um
nothing's true anymore
um objectively speaking but it's true
for your group or tribe and therefore
because it's true for your group or
tribe it's real
uh and that's very very interesting
because then we start getting into all
kinds of smoke and mirrors and Truth
Chambers and Echo Chambers on on the web
as well but yes you're absolutely right
um group Norms
um group mores group uh the the idea of
of stories and anecdotes which swirl
around a group to keep groups together
and over the centuries and over the
years
become fused in truth
and as a result of that
um these kinds of things the brain has
has evolved a propensity uh to distrust
uh information coming from other groups
and to place perhaps too much trust and
validity any information which is a
currency in your own group uh because
obviously you know you you you've got
something in common with those people in
your group uh you've got a common goal
you've got a common background and of
course with any con man we'll tell you
uh people are way more likely to believe
you if you are one of them
than if you're an outsider didn't you
spend a bunch of time with con men
didn't you do a ton of research with
them what happened there I I did
um that was my first book actually
flypnosis
um and uh it start you know what Chris
it started with with my old man mate I
grew up in uh in in London my my dad I
remember Only Fools and Horses Don't You
well my dad was like dull boy I mean he
even looked like the old boy
um he could always make a joke because
they'll shaving agreement with the
Taliban mate he could so he could he
could sell anything or anybody in the
old man and he was a psychopath he
wasn't a violent man
he was ruthless he was Fearless he was
Shameless I never once saw him
embarrassed and he could do things that
most normal people would find
psychologically impossible and it was
pretty much him that got me started even
as a young lad into psychology and he
was he with a con man uh so that was my
roots basically and I mean I'll give you
an example I mean I always remember one
time I must have been about 10 or 11.
uh we got hold of a load of gear I used
to help him on the stall and uh he got
hold of a load of Diaries
uh calendar Diaries you know and um
they were very different to the usual
kinds of stuff that we got our hands on
because they were actually good they
were actually nice these Diaries they
were they were leather they were
embossed they were Slimline and there
was a very good reason for that anyway I
always remember one Saturday afternoon
on the stall we knocked out about 300 of
these they went like hotcakes uh and
after about a couple of hours and we got
back to the flat and remember I'm only
about 10 or 11. I couldn't resist it I
said that Dad I said here I said oh
Diaries went like okay so they were nice
weren't they they were you know they
were leathering but they were thin and
he goes oh yes I know we're thin all
right there's a reason for that
I said well what was that and he said
April was missing and I'm not joking
Chris he gets one out of drawer Mike
January February March May
I see it here you remember Mornington I
said we've just sold to Adriana these
down I said what are we going to do I'll
never forget it Chris he said nothing
for now son but come March the 31st make
sure you pack your swimming trunk
because we're off to tomorrow Molina for
six weeks that was the kind of Geezer he
was so when I eventually kind of um he's
dead now so listen if there's any
coppers watching it's long gone long
gone
um when I uh eventually uh started
studying psychology I was obviously very
interested in how people were good at
persuasion like the old man
um and eventually after I you know got
my PhD in all that
um I uh wrote a book on uh persuasion
um because I was interested to see
whether
there were limits to persuasion could if
you had enough skill
uh would you be able to persuade anybody
to do anything
um or were there limits on on persuasion
um and I've got I mean I'll give you
another example of my old man giving his
arms again a young kid helped him on the
stall uh took me out to an Indian
restaurant up in Brick Lane the East End
of London uh that night and just as he's
about to play the ball this is crucial
Chris I'll never forget it Justin's
about a church paid a bill
he turns around and he says Kev if
there's if there's one thing I want you
to remember in life son it's this
persuasion ain't about getting people to
do what they don't want to do it's about
giving people a reason to do what they
do want to do very very if you're a
salesperson who's trying to get someone
to do something bear that in mind okay
Pusher going for an open door and he
says watch and learn so with that give
an example what he done he took his
spoon and he tinkled it against his
glass right entire Restaurant Falls
silent told you with a site button he
gets to his feet
and he says right I'd just like to thank
everyone for coming
now I know that some of you have come
from just around the corner some of you
come from a little bit further afield
but I want you to know that you're all
very welcome it's very much appreciated
oh there's a party across the road in
the King's Arms uh which we'll be
hosting a little drinks reception later
tonight there uh you're all welcome to
pop along at which point he starts to
clap right which point the entire
restaurant starts to collapse didn't it
so picture the singers all of a sudden
we've got a restaurant full of people
never seen us before never seen each
other before all applauding politely
because right none of them want to be
seen as a gay crashes at a party right
that was a genius of it well as we leave
him remember I'm only about nine or ten
I can't resist it
Chris and I'll never forget he says of
course not some but let me tell you
something that lot in the restaurant are
my mate Malcolm he's just taken over his
landlord who make a few quid tonight now
can you imagine the kind of balls that
you would need to even think about
pulling a stunt like that but that's the
kind of thing he did so having grown up
with me old man
always in the back of my mind was
can anyone persuade anyone to do
anything or are they limits so I had
contacts at the time
um various branches of the police
um so there used to be a show called
hustle on BBC years ago you might
remember it um not the real Hustle but
the one with Adrian Leicester which was
a group of long con artists who were
psychological geniuses
so I had access to a couple of guys like
that for you guys like that and I spent
about
um about half a year hanging out and
looking at what they did and I wanted to
know basically mate who knew more about
persuasion me who was the buffing who
learned it out the books or them who
were the Evil Geniuses of persuasion who
derived it all from first principles
living on their wits on the street
um and I would say it was pretty much a
draw
um I knew all the technical terms they
knew how to do it
um and the bottom line
um because I'm sure people aren't going
to run off and buy flypnosis um oh yeah
you never know
um the bottom line is if look there's a
lot of science on persuasion and
influence but it boils down to this
if you can get someone to like you
and if you can frame what you want so
that it appeals to the other person's
self-interest and not your own
you're pretty much there because no
one's going to do something for someone
they don't like
and we're all going to do something that
benefits ourselves so if you can frame
something so it's in someone's
self-interest and also get them to like
you
then pretty much you're home and dried
okay and I'll give you a great example
of self-interest one of my favorite
stories in Persuasion I think it was
Baron delphont many years ago with Lord
Lou Gray's brother TV Mogul and um he is
on the Grapevine that there's a young
man who's looking for a job this young
guy pops into his office one day true
story this
and he says I'm looking for a job and
and delphon says right here on the
Grapevine that you're a genius Persuader
so I've got a little challenge for you
see that water jug and he puts his water
jug on the desk in front of me says see
this water jug here just like they said
I want you to sell it to me right it's a
nightmare situation right so the young
blog thinks about it for a minute and
undaunted he gets three feet and he
Wander Over the corner of the room and
he picks up the waste paper basket
carries it over to delphon's desk
empties the contents of the wife's paper
basket out on a desk in front of him so
there's I don't know all kinds of Bits
of Paper on there whatever whatever and
he takes delphonce cigar lighter
takes the water jug away puts it out of
his reach and sets light to the pile of
rubbish in front of it with a cigar
light and he says to delfon right how
much are you going to give me for it
as a as he's basically his office is
about to burst into flames that is how
you persuade someone to buy a water jug
son all right you basically what you do
is you reframe the situation so that all
of a sudden it's really in their
self-interest to buy off you so you
can't change the value of the water jug
objectively but by manipulating the
context you can change it subjectively
so the bottom line of flypnosis hanging
out with all them con artists if you
want to persuade someone to do something
basically get them to like it which is
why humor is very important if you can
make someone laugh it's very it's it's
very important uh I think it was I think
it was Victor Borgia the Argentinian
playwright who said that humor is the
shortest distance between two people
laughter is the shortest distance
between two people so make them laugh
get them to like you frame it in their
self-interest and you've got the
ingredients for persuasion
draw the line for me between that
persuasion and super categories and how
super categories can be so persuasive I
think there was some a very useful
Innovative language that was used around
the brexit
marketing campaign as well what what's
going on there
yeah well right and wrong us and them
are basically
um
categories super categories which have
um evolved
um through many many years of evolution
so going back to our prehistoric
ancestors on the Savannahs of East
Africa they were living in small groups
so uh Us and Them
is basically that in group bias that I
was talking to you about okay so we have
a bias to favor members of our own group
against bias uh against
um uh basically uh discriminating
um and um and favoring members of an out
group okay uh right versus wrong
uh basically the moral instincts evolved
to keep groups together and we kind of
touched on that a little bit earlier so
if you don't have a sense of right and
wrong then you are more likely just to
act out of a complete and utter
self-interest rather than the good of
the group so if you don't once you've
got the Us and Them
uh categorization established in your
brain you kind of need a moral uh
categorization between right and wrong
otherwise that group wouldn't stick
together and the third Super category uh
to go with us and them right wrong is
fight or flight so basically that is you
know the ability to either move towards
a stimulus in your environment or to
move away from it uh so can I eat it or
is it going to eat me so fight or flight
right or wrong
often them uh evolved it not quite in
that order evolved fight flight us them
right wrong obviously okay and they're
all survival what I call Super
categories there's three super
categories that our brains have evolved
through millions of years of evolution
now if you can use persuasion if you can
set your language up
to tap into those three super categories
that our brains have evolved long ago uh
then whether you're right or whether
you're wrong Chris you're going to get
people sit up and and take interest mate
so if you think about the brexit
argument as you rightly pointed out
fight or flight okay you think about the
language that was used in the early days
by Nigel farage by Boris Johnson by the
exit Lobby look
are we going to stand up to these
European bureaucrats are we going to let
them roll all over us fight or flight
language right Us and Them what about
these crazy edicts and decrees that are
coming over from Brussels you know about
bananas being too spendy or whatever
um oh is this what are we going to do
about this are we going to just you know
acquiesce to this right or wrong is it
right to allow Europe to dictate to us
rules in our own country
you can see through the rhetoric fight
flight us them right wrong if you can
frame your language so that presses
those ancient super category buttons in
our brains again as I say whether you're
right or whether you're wrong you're
going to get people to sit up and take
notice that's what Trump did by the way
in America probably going to come as no
surprise make America great again fight
or flight we're going to fight against
immigrants we're going to build a wall
between the USA and Mexico that's the US
and them again right and wrong okay
you've got them all there in Trump's
rhetoric and it was very funny when I
was going back to flypnosis
great sorry um I interviewed a a top uh
QC in London and
um I once asked him I said what makes a
great Barrister what makes a great QC I
wasn't interested in the difference
between what makes a bad one and a good
one that's not interesting the interest
is in most things what's the difference
between good and great
and he was a pupil master in his London
Chambers and a pupil Master basically
means that um that's where um people
with law degrees
um the cream of the cream from London
Oxford and Cambridge go to study to
learn their trade you've got these
various Chambers around London it's a
little bit like teaching hospitals for
law basically yeah uh and he said well
look Kev he said you know obviously I'll
get the cream and a crop coming to me
he said from all the top universities he
said so you know the fact they've got
Brilliant Minds the fact that they have
eidetic uh photographic memories for
facts and figures the fact that they are
able to get their heads around a details
of a case really really quickly is entry
level he said that's entry level they're
all like that and he said but the one
difference between the people that
really become great uh and Forge a
stellar career for themselves in
advocacy and people who are good
uh is something you can't teach
and he said it's the ability to tell a
story
he said that is a god-given talent that
if you have that natural ability
alongside
the other characteristics I've told you
said that kind of separates out uh the
great from The Good the wheat from the
chef and I'll never forget it Chris
coming back to what I was saying
um
he said information
travels around the brain like
electricity around a circuit it takes
the path of least resistance so Kevin
said if you and I are up against each
other in a court of law and you can
assemble the facts of the case so that
it goes around the minds of the jury
quicker than I've assembled the facts of
the case you're gonna win no matter
whether that's right or wrong you're
gonna win because basically it goes
around the minds of the jury quicker
than my set of facts or the way I've
arranged them so it's very similar to
the super categories uh what you've got
to remember Chris the bottom line here
is that our brains conflate Simplicity
for truth the simpler that I can make it
for you to do something the more likely
you are going to do it and there's a
number of different ways we've already
kind of talked about that you can you
can do that but you're not going to do
something for me mate if I make it
difficult for you uh it's just it's a
lot of persuasion is common sense so you
know as I say it's get someone to like
you make it simple make it in their own
self-interest you're halfway there well
you're more than halfway there you're 85
percent there we see this online as well
so a lot of content creators some of the
ones that are the most well followed the
most popular
are the ones that have got the most
fluent speech because fluency is used as
a proxy for truthfulness and I think a
big part of that is absolutely
Simplicity that
people are able to understand what they
are saying because the friction between
their brain and their mouth
is as unencumbered as it's possible to
be the language that's being used is as
precise as possible it's no more words
it's no fewer words it's no more complex
it's exactly where it needs to be and
that is I mean all of this stuff that
you've brought up
um the weaponizing of in-group out group
bias this is something else that we see
like the world that I exist in is online
content creation right so but yeah I'm
always very cautious whenever I see a
community of people whether it be online
or or elsewhere that appears to be bound
together not over the mutual love of an
in-group but over the mutual hatred of
an out group you see this with the
social justice movement online which
seems to be very fragilely held together
by pointing at other Heretics people
that aren't a part of them well okay
what you're telling me there is that all
you need to do is find someone that is
currently a part of the in-group that
can be pointed at as part of the out
group and now they're shaved off the
outside this is the ever increasing
Purity spiral right ever more distilled
and and concentrated into the middle and
you yeah I mean I had a look at this uh
I love that by the way I love that
Purity spot that's a great phrase Purity
it's apparently it's actually a thing
I'm just made that made that up but I'll
have you okay no no it exists online and
uh I learned about the difference in
Prejudice between race and accent have
you heard about this oh yeah
um yeah go into a bit more detail I
probably have but um so one of my
friends William Costello evolutionary
psychologist out here in Austin at UT
um he was explaining the fact that there
is a greater prejudice against people of
the same race with a different accent
Than People of A different race with the
same accent and the explanation for this
is pretty simple that evolutionarily
ancestrally it would have been very
unlikely for us to encounter somebody of
A different race but very likely for us
to encounter someone that has a slightly
different dialect or a slightly
different accent and what that means is
that you have very interesting
um Crossing using prejudices and
counteracting prejudices for instance if
you were to see an Arab man that walked
into the room but then started speaking
like somebody that was from the south
end of London or whatever it might be if
you have someone who's race and accent
do not line up for instance I mean
everybody can think about this if you
were to see somebody walk into the room
that deserve a different race to you but
speaks with the same accent yeah you
would immediately think well there's we
have an awful awful lot in common you
you have to forget you forget about the
fact that they're of A different race
but then you flip that round okay let's
have somebody walk into the room who is
of the same race as you yeah but has an
entirely different sort of accent there
is immediately a big distance and I I
just thought that that totally blew my
mind okay you're telling me that there
is more prejudice against people with
different accents than people of
different races like just totally it
makes perfect sense uh the way you've
explained it and William Costello
um absolutely nailed it right on the
head there the thing I would add to that
um is I was talking to uh probably
shouldn't mention who it is I was
talking to um one of the UK's top
Impressionists
um the other day uh and interestingly uh
we were talking about impressionism
um as um as an art form and as a form of
humor
um and he said that he'd come across
people actually who had pointed the
finger at Impressionists as cultural
appropriators which is a very
interesting argument
um now whereas I don't buy it uh whereas
you know I think we have an innate
Fascination for different voices coming
out of um the same person it's very
incongruous it the incongruity principle
is very powerful in in all kinds of
things that's why we're so fascinated
with serial killers for example because
they appear on the outside to be very
normal but of course they've got these
you know horrendous alter egos raging
behind the scenes
um if you have different voices coming
out of the same person
uh then there is a real fascination with
that so we're fascinated by him
personally there's an impressionist but
actually recently there's been recent
Lobby saying well actually you know if
you're doing different accents or taking
people off then why is that not cultural
appropriation let's not go down that
road mate because that's another two
hours we could sit there talking about
that one but it's a good one to throw
out there but interestingly it's it's
it's it's very uh
when you look at when you talk to
someone
and again this is something that this
guy this impersonated this impressionist
uh who I was talking to uh delved into
and I'm sure you do it uh I certainly do
it if you really like someone
sometimes without knowing it you end up
talking a little bit like them when
you're in conversation with someone you
might adopt a little bit of their speech
patterns might not be their accent
sometimes it is in extreme cases but you
might unconsciously mirror uh the tone
or the speed uh at which or the tempo
which they're speaking so the voice of
somebody is something that we find it
very difficult not to empathize with
so that's where William Costello was
coming from there that's one that's
another reason an empathy reason when we
look when we hear voices
um it's it's one of those things that is
a marker of how we gain an impression of
someone
um and we're very very susceptible to to
to to sound coming out of people's uh of
lips and how they sound
let me throw some bro signs at you is it
the case that accents get locked in and
are less likely to change as you grow up
but are more likely to change if you are
younger let's say that you spend the
first seven years of your life in
Ireland and then you move to America or
whatever you're going to end up with
pretty much just an American accent and
if you maybe make the move at sort of 13
or 14 you're going to end up with sort
of an Irish American accent after maybe
10 years yeah
would that be adaptive in case
ancestrally you ended up merging with
another tribe perhaps being taken over
by another tribe and it would be in your
interests to align yourself in terms of
your accent with the accent of the new
tribe that you have joined because that
is going to be one of the key
determinants in not making you an
outsider yeah I mean you know what Chris
you should I don't know if you've ever
studied psychology maybe you should
definitely give it a go I mean I'd never
heard that before
um never thought of that before I think
it's an absolutely cool Theory
um and I can see that there's I could
instantly pull out and they have a lot
of evidence to to back that up
um absolutely the ability and you know
I'm going to do a study actually because
no one's really looked at it what makes
people why are some of us really good at
changing our accents and why are some of
us not so good what makes great
impression is great Impressionists
there's all kinds of different things
there's the the flexibility of the vocal
tract for example so there's all going
to be all kinds of individual
differences in this but yeah the ability
to change your accent and to blend in uh
would indeed uh confer
um an evolutionary Advantage uh going
forward absolutely
going back to your point about
Simplicity
um which is related to this
um
there was a study and how you know our
brains conflate Simplicity with truth
there was a wonderful study done a few
years ago which looked at menus in
restaurants
um and two groups I'm going for the top
of my head now so two groups of
participants uh were given exactly the
same menus uh except for one crucial uh
difference one of the menus was printed
in a very difficult to read typeface a
fancy one and the other half the menus
was printed in a very simple easy to
read typeface one half of the
participants got the easy to read menu
the other half of the participants got
the difficult read menu uh the menus
were exactly the same once they'd read
the menus they were then asked how easy
do you think the recipe would be to cook
not read but cook it what do you think
they found well you've got their ahead
of me already haven't you those people
that were given the menus in the tricky
type faces thought it would be way more
difficult to cook than those people that
were given it in the simple type faces
and moreover were way more likely way
less likely to say that they'd actually
give it a go so moral of the story for
restaurateurs out there uh because I'm
sure it would be the same in how food
tastes in fact I think studies might
have been done I couldn't swear to it I
think Studies have been done on that
they're exactly the same dish printed in
a simple typeface
uh I think if I'm rightly saying I think
Studies have been done on this uh
actually taste better or rated as
tasting better anyway than exactly the
same dish that you've ordered in a
tricky
um uh typeface in a restaurant so
there's a there's a physiological
example of how Simplicity interferes
with is it without literal without with
our physical perception I could have
seen that going either way I could have
seen it that people would have presumed
that the more difficult typeface the
more difficult dish to cook would
perhaps be of a more intricate yeah
worthy worthy of a higher price point a
few other tips I've learned from Rory
Sutherland from Ogilvy about that anyway
oh I know I know Rory he's a legend he's
coming well coming on in a couple of
weeks again you better tell him to leave
his Vape at home
he'll have two I don't know whether
you've seen him on podcast but he has
two he switches between them but yeah
guys like a chimney so he's a good lap
um a couple of things restaurateurs
should do if you're a budding restaurant
to uh first thing take the uh currency
denomination off your menu
yeah it seems that if you just have the
numbers rather than the currency
denomination people forget about the
fact that they're spending money another
thing use angering bias so have some
very nice expensive platter first up on
the page when you people land on it that
should be up there now a final one I
don't think this is used with
restaurants but I could imagine a way
that you might be able to work it into
either the menu or the advertising this
is a Rory thing we actually use this in
night Pro nightclub promo
um if you involve the viewer in the
completion of an advert they have you
get a lot more attentional time so for
instance if you were to ask a question
this this has happened a bunch
um like who should be the next prime
minister of the UK and then it could be
r underscore Shi right and like you
already can complete it yourself but the
fact like that's obviously like an
absolutely lame example that the UK
government very well made no I know what
you mean yeah yeah
um involving the reader of an advert in
the active completion of it and the
participation of experiencing it has way
way way more attentional input from them
and I'm imagining that if you had a way
of constructing the menu maybe like the
dish of the day could be up on a board
but if you themed it appropriately that
yeah the dish of the day is something
you almost have to do a little bit of
working out for yourself or whatever it
might be uh I can imagine that that
would that would probably be pretty
effective at drawing people in another
great Point Chris also that's how
construct your own pizzas work mate in
uh pizza restaurants so sometimes you go
in you can order the spicy hot one you
can order the margarita uh but then
there's an option which says um uh we'll
you know create your own uh so uh you're
absolutely right this is uh a uh a
technique which has been known to sales
people for many years not so much in
what you're saying in you know creating
your own pizza has been done for years
the idea of creating a specials menu
board is pretty cool actually uh that
that's very good I like that
um uh getting a bit suspicious about you
mate I think you I think you've studied
more psychology here later on uh but
it's called in sales
um it's called foot in the door and it's
a similar technique so if you involve
someone in the decision you're way more
likely to get a closure so here's it
here's the deal right imagine you go to
a department store or a shop uh and
you're looking at a shirt or a pair of
trash or pair of shoes or whatever uh
and the person the salesperson will say
try it onto
uh and you go okay you are way more
likely to buy that object once you've
tried it on than if you haven't tried it
on because you've spent we have our
brains like to remain consistent so the
way our brains will then work Chris is
they will say you've taken the trouble
to try this on you've there's obviously
something about it you like okay
otherwise you wouldn't have taken the
trouble to tie it on if you spent two or
three minutes in the changing room the
cubicle looking at yourself in the
mirror thinking yeah no no no no yeah
maybe if it's a 50 50 you're going to
come out and think I spent three bloody
minutes trying that on well
I'm gonna get something out of coming
into this shop so you might well buy
that if you're in any doubts 50 50 or
you might go looking for something else
in the shop so again if you can involve
someone in something if you can get them
to make this as the key word mate if you
can get them to make a commitment
that's the key then whether that's in
advertising whether it's in
relationships whether it's in sales same
technique you're way more likely to get
a result just coming back to one more
thing you said there about
um about in groups and out groups before
I forget it
um one of the things when we get online
you're talking about your online thing
and I've you know studied online quite a
bit uh it's it's a it's a fantastic
laboratory of of
um social psychology
um
you find that when you get situations
where never has our identity uh Chris in
any era in history depended so much on
what we are seeing
or perceived to say or believe uh that's
what social media has done it's it's a
massive petri dish it's a massive prism
of belief and we're all in the public
Arena and so when you're in a situation
where you are arguing in a public forum
it becomes almost like a surrogate court
of law and so we don't think like
scientists we think like lawyers we
don't try to get at the truth and we're
all guilty of this we don't try to get
at the truth Chris we try to win the
bloody argument mate and that's what
happens on social media that's why you
get people becoming more and more
entrenched one of the reasons why you
say you get groups that are knitted
together purely through hatred of an out
group rather than any shared sense of
value that they might have and what you
then get is groups that become vacant
become vacuous and very toxic mate
that's the psychology behind that I've
Got a Friend Gwenda Bogle who is been on
the show a bunch of times he's
phenomenal and everyone needs to go and
check out his sub stack this is a quote
from him the rise of social media is the
primary form is of social interaction
changed the way that we judge people we
once used to judge people mostly based
on their deeds but in the age of social
media we judge people mostly based on
their words and opinions because that's
really all we see of them since we're
defined by our opinions there is a
pressure to have an opinion on
everything problem is people generally
don't have the time or the will to
research everything they're expected to
have an opinion on so they copy the
opinions of others and the result is
that there is precious few original
thinkers out there the culture war is
largely two armies of NPCs being
ventriloquized by a handful of actual
thinkers wonderful well I couldn't have
put it better myself mate and and also
you can add to that uh we were talking
you brought up earlier the need for
complexity the need for closure
um you look at the vehicles on Which
social media operate you've got very
short attention spans you've got so much
information out there how do you get
someone's attention in the information
jungle well you make something simple
you make something extreme there's no
room for nuance on any platform really
and so what your frame was just saying
is absolutely true but that's also
compounded by the fact that actually
things are simplified Beyond measures
that they should be simplified
um and so yeah absolutely right you've
got that what you were talking about
that Purity spiral or impurity spiral
maybe might be a better correct yeah a
uh the complexity of the truth is
inconvenient for both sides
absolutely right yeah definitely
dude let's wind this one up I really
appreciated you today I think he works
fantastic uh where should people go if
they want to keep up to date with the
things that you do online
um if you want to follow me on Chase
Chris by the way it was absolutely
wonderful mate really enjoy chatting
with you uh thanks for having me on
um uh my uh social media handles Twitter
and Instagram I'm too old with Tick Tock
mate
um is at the real doctor Dr Kev so Dr
for doctor at the real Dr Kev uh you'll
find me on there
um and if you want to check out some of
the books wisdom of psychopaths probably
the the one that started all over or
going a couple of books I wrote with
Andy McNabb if you want to become if you
want to become a little bit more
assertive and successful
um you might want to check out the good
Psychopaths guide to success which I
wrote with Andy McNabb the SAS Soldier
who's a uh who who is a psychopath by
the way Dev I appreciate you thank you
Chris cheers mate what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]